18 samedi ça suffit il faut s'imaginer
que nos collègues on prenne vraiment ce
qu'on peut dire plein la gueule et il ya
quelque chose qui n'est pas du tout
normal dans la réaction d'un mouvement
social c'est l'introduction de deux
milieux extrêmes de gens extrêmement
organisés aguerris à une certaine forme
de confrontation avec les forces de
l'ordre et qui met en difficulté et nos
collègues et la démocratie et tous nos
citoyens bouffer du flic c'est devenu
quelque chose à la mode et nos collègues
en ont ras-le-bol si vous voulez de
comment dire d'être pris pour cible
systématiquement les policiers sont-ils
à bout beaucoup d'heures supplémentaires
une certaine forme de lassitude bien sûr
qu'il s'installe et surtout beaucoup de
désillusion face comment dire aux
violences des citoyens de certains
citoyens face à nos collègues
qu'attendez vous
on attend surtout des moyens matériels
du moyens matériels du moyens humains et
une certaine forme de considération de
notre hiérarchie pour le travail qui est
effectué depuis ses nombreuses semaines